[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue pour ce nouveau
rendez vous de votre journal
d'information locale voici les titres de
ce 28 février
elle les suit de la fuite
d'hydrocarbures à authouillet le
'pipeline' de l'entreprise total a
déversé des milliers de litres de
pétrole comment va se dérouler la
dépollution des quelques 8 hectares le
salon de l'agriculture 2010 9 fermera
ses portes le 3 mars au soir il ne vous
reste que quelques jours pour aller à la
rencontre des exploitants yvelinois tour
d'horizon à suivre et puis elle fait
partie de ces mères qui jette l'épongé
véronique côté millard assure qu'elle ne
se représentera pas en 2020 en plateau
elle nous expliquera notamment pourquoi
huit hectares de champs touché mais
aussi des rivières des ruisseaux où la
fuite d'hydrocarbures survenue en tout
début de semaine à auteuil a été
qualifiée de marée noire à l'échelle
locale par les associations de
protection de l'environnement
sur place hier pour constater les dégâts
le ministre d'état françois de rugy a
d'ores et déjà annoncé et qu'il serait
extrêmement ferme avec total
propriétaire du pipeline à l'origine de
l'accident
il y aura bien sûr une enquête
une recherche en responsabilité et tout
sera à la charge du groupe total tous
les travaux de dépollution tous les
travaux d'intervention actuels et futurs
seront à la charge du groupe total de
même que l'indemnisation des
agriculteurs aujourd'hui qu'ils y
subissent ce préjudice de pollution au
pétrole
et si aujourd'hui l'incident semble
circonscrit se pose la question de la
dépollution comment nettoyer quelques
900 mètres cubes de pétrole brut écouter
à présent l'un des responsables de total
on a une équipe qui sur 24 heures sur 24
avec du pompage
d'abord les scada sion terre c'est
extrêmement important pour limiter la
façon dont l'écoulement se fait
ensuite on a des pelleteuses vous voyez
derrière qui préparent des terres et qui
commence à excaver des terres la
préoccupation essentielle c'est de
limiter la zone de pollution de
s'assurer qu'aucun hydrocarbure ne
dépasse cette zone qu'on a des limites
et aujourd'hui reste que deux
agriculteurs céréaliers ont aujourd'hui
perdu leurs récoltes annuelles un comité
de suivi est hebdomadaire doit être mis
en place et une enquête environnementale
elle devrait avoir lieu dans une
quinzaine de jours le salon de
l'agriculture un rendez vous médiatique
important pour les exploitants venus de
toute la france et ceux des yvelines ont
forcément répondu présent manon par aldo
et aller leur rendre une petite visite
sur leur stand au salon de l'agriculture
2010 9 dégustation de produits du
terroir français
découvertes gustatives visite
incontournable des animaux et petit
bisou pour certains je compte devenir l
agriculture dans quelques mois
et ça me semblait intéressant il c'est
une opportunité pour moi de venir de
voir un peu autre chose
et parmi tous les stands du salon
bientôt du vin 100% yvelinois en 2017 la
winery parisienne a planté ses premiers
pieds de vigne à d'avron elle veut
réinventer la filière viticole en
ile-de-france privé pour nous c'était de
reproduire des vins dans la plus grande
l'ancien plus grande région
tipl de france qui est l'île de france
pour produire des grands vins dans la
région sur la plaine de versailles
la première cuvée est annoncée pour 2020
côté assiette la ferme d alu et propose
des légumes anciens et nouveaux
sur les étalages topinambours radis noir
route à bagua j'ai une cinquantaine
d'hectares
fruits et légumes je revends sur les
marchés
ile de france car entre aux choux de
bruxelles rouge novembre vraiment des
légumes qui sortent de l'ordinaire
le département des yvelines est le
deuxième territoire agricole d'île de
france
il participe au salon pour la deuxième
fois avec les hauts-de-seine et ils sont
complémentaires parce que l'agriculture
c'est une production et une consommation
et si les yvelines sont un département
producteur ce que les hauts-de-seine ne
sont pas les hauts-de-seine comme les
yvelines d'ailleurs sont des
départements consommateurs et en
particulier consommateurs dans nos
cantines scolaires de nos collèges les
yvelines favorisent les produits locaux
et intègre les produits issus de
l'agriculture biologique au concours
général agricole
y a eu la médaille d'argent sera yaourts
à l'abricot destinés à la restauration
collective pour les enfants des écoles
du département
le diam on va envoyer près de 30 à 40
mille fois par mois qui sont des dires
cantine hôpitaux le territoire des
yvelines est composé de 90 mille
hectares d'espacés agricoles
avec près de 1000 exploitations
l'agriculture c'est un marqueur fort des
yvelines aider à l'installation et au
renouvellement des générations
il faut installer des jeunes
agriculteurs des jeunes agricultrices et
donc on y travaille en les aidant
financièrement on les aide aussi à se
transformer au niveau écologique
énergétique
alexandra dublanche également adjointe
au maire de sartrouville n'est pas la
seule à vouloir mettre en avant les
agricultrices dans les stands du salon
clémentine errigo miss france agricole
élu le 15 décembre est présente c'est
plus les vieux barbu au fin fond de la
montagne qu'il ya vraiment un nouveau
souffle dans le monde agricole avec la
jeunesse et les femmes dans
l'agriculture
concilier développement urbain et
développement économique agricole un
enjeu que les visiteurs ont apprécié
serment
rendre son nom
on fait voir beaucoup des choses qui à
paris justement il n'y a pas de vingt
cinq années et à chaque fois j'ai eu
l'occasion d'accompagner mon petit fils
j'ai eu pas mal de nouveautés c'est tout
du côté bio
et goûter les produits éventuellement
vous pouvez encore faire un tour le
salon de l'agriculture se termine ce
dimanche 3 mars l'invité de ce journal à
présent véronique côté millard bonsoir
bateau mère a eu des idées
clayes-sous-bois vous êtes élu depuis
2001 et vous l'avez est d'ores et déjà
annoncés vous ne serez pas candidate à
un nouveau mandat en 2020 vous faites
partie de ces mères qui jette l'épongé
comme on dit en quelque sorte
expliquez-nous pourquoi oui oui et non
puisque j'avais annoncé en 2014 aux
dernières élections municipales que ce
serait mon dernier mandat le troisième
mandat donc j'avais déjà prévenu que je
ne referai pas un quatrième mandat
est ce qu'il ya un ras-le-bol
aujourd'hui vous êtes déjà exprimé sur
ce sujet là et ça c'est certain
c'est certes un bon mois j'avais pris
cette décision avant parce que je
considère qu'être élu c'est pas une
c'est pas n'y a pas de carrière
politique entre guillemets c'est pas un
aboutissement et que donc je souhaite
maintenant prendre un nouveau départ
mais c'est à dire que je ne vais pas
partir à veut pas partir avec leur grève
auquel j'aurais pensé pour devoir partir
et laisser la place de mai reverser la
fonction de maire est dévalorisé mes
administrés sont très exigeants c'est
devenu très extrêmement compliqué parce
que d'abord il ya on est dans un climat
de défiance on est dans une crise
institutionnelle sans précédent
on voit tous les jours et on est dans
une période de recentralisation qui n'a
fait que de simplifier et qui entre
autres sont responsables les lois ma
part mais les loups un autre sur le cas
nous les élus on est dans des opci
les les compétences que non exerçait
d'une façon complètement autonome sont
déléguées à des intercommunalités
donc ça change complètement le rapport
qu'on a avec le citoyen ce rapport de
proximité conduit n'avons pas forcément
vers qui se tourner quand il s'y
rencontrent certaines difficultés tout
tout à fait on a des problèmes
financiers qui sont épouvantables
puisqu'on a de moins en moins de deux
dotations de l'état pour ce qui concerne
ma commune on avait on a baissé de o na
plus important de dotation globale de
fonctionnement alors qu'elle était de
20% il ya il ya encore eu une dizaine
d'années et 25% même donc plus de moyens
financiers plus d'autonomie fiscale
on ne supprime en plus sa taxe
d'habitation et les compétences que nous
exercions dans notre commune y compris
surtout la gestion des services de
proximité ne sont plus de notre pouvoir
puisque son ire il part dans une
intercommunalité
ce qui a changé entre le début de votre
mandat en 2001 le premier mandat est
aujourd'hui en 2019 c'est cette
intercommunalité auquel la ville des
clayes-sous-bois n'appartenait pas à
saint quentin en yvelines
ça a changé les choses en bien malgré
tout ou c'est un handicap pour votre
commune en virant bien parce qu'il ya
des choses c'est intéressant si vous
voulez de pouvoir mutualiser de
travailler sur un territoire qui est
quand même le deuxième pôle économique
d'île de france et qui est qu'il ya une
territoire de l'innovation il ya plein
de choses intéressantes à faire
après c'est celle des lois qui obligent
donc les délégations de compétences nous
on a tous coefficient d'intégration
fiscale c'est à dire que 60% des
compétences son intérêt communautaire
lorsqu'elles sont délégués qui ne laisse
plus tôt pratiquement plus d'autonomie
aux mères puisque c'est leur chambre du
conseil communautaire qui va décider
parce que vous devez faire ce votre
commune c'est pas gênant dans certains
domaines je viens dans le domaine des
déchets de domaine des transports ça ne
pose aucun problème
après nos mails de développement
économique c'est dommage parce que la
proximité qu'on avait avec les
investisseurs en direct ou là beaucoup
moins
et puis alors dans d'autres domaines
comme d'un domaine de la gestion des
services de proximité c'est une
catastrophe
on a la compétence éclairage a été
délégué on a pu le mobilier urbain on
peut nous imposer du mobilier urbain
la réactivité que moi j'avais quand il y
avait un problème un container de vernon
vide etc
j'ai appelé tout de suite l'entreprise
il venait si vous n'êtes pas assez
rapidement je faisais venir mais de
services techniques et cet effet dans la
journée un trou sur la voirie moi je le
répare est dans la journée avec mes
services maintenant ça peut prendre un
temps plus que certains y la population
ne comprend pas que n'a plus de
lisibilité d'abord par manque
d'autonomie financière parce que ne les
services qu'on faisait avant direct on
ne les fait plus et on n'arrête pas de
se faire je dire disputés par les gens
qui même quand ils vous aiment bien dix
ans vous aime bien mais à quoi vous
servez même le maire ben justement c'est
une question que je me pose donc vous
l'avez dit c'est un soulagement vous
allez quitter finalement avec un certain
soulagement cette fonction de maire en
2020 est ce que je vis très mal cette
situation je me suis toujours investi
avec une passion avec enthousiasme et
j'ai toujours pris mes responsabilités
et les risques elle avec et maintenant
devoir me voir imposer des choses qui ne
que je ne porte pas forcément c'est
quelque chose qui est en plus de devoir
dire aux habitants maui sujet de fermer
les gens comprennent c'est sait pas on
peut pas comprendre donc c'est beaucoup
de stress était extrêmement frustrant ça
veut dire qu'aujourd'hui il ya des
dossiers qui n'avancent plus vous avez
encore des priorités sur l'ess sur la
fin de ce mandat oui j'ai des dossiers
qui malheureusement me prenez trois mois
et en années ont pris du retard parce
que justement les procédures sont
devenus tellement lourde maintenant qu'
il ya un décalage il n'y a pas du tout
la même la même réactivité oui j'ai une
résidence de personnes âgées que
j'aurais dû sortir il ya bien longtemps
et qui n'est pas encore le permis ça
devrait commencer les travaux on espère
l'année prochaine mais voilà j'ai perdu
j'ai pu j'ai perdu un énorme et il ya
des exemples journée je pense que je
vais écrire un livre là-dessus le
raconter pour une seconde fille dans
cette soirée temps dans ce contexte là
mais au moins est ce que vous préparer
l'avenir est ce que vous avez pensé à
passer la main avant la fin du mandat on
voit dans certaines communes aussi des
mères qui qui passe un petit peu le
relais ça se fait souvent avant les
élections est ce que ce sera votre cas
ma préparation de l'avenir c'est d'aller
jusqu'au bout de mon mandat jusqu'au
dernier jour est justement de conduire
le maximum de dossiers auxquels nous
avons tous l'équipe municipale donc
auquel on s'est investi et qu'on
voudrait porter jusqu'au bout tant
dénoncé votre succession que non
d'autant prise que j'ai la nation êtes à
la région donc c'est de faire avancer
des dossiers
et voilà est d'aller le met dans le
maximum possible de notre engagement que
nous avons pris donc faso face aux
électeurs jusqu'au dernier tour et
jusqu'à la dernière minute et avec
toujours le même enthousiasme vous
soutiendrez néanmoins une liste pendant
la campagne l'année prochaine bah
écoutez j'ai pas la visibilité
nécessaire pour vous répondre
aujourd'hui parce que j'ai pas de cauna
par l'opposition je mets le passionné
sur le candidat sur les migrants déclaré
alors après je sais que ce qui est
d'assez de lier curieuse c'est que l'on
constate à la fois mais y'a pas sur le
plan national
kylie a énormément de mer qui disent ne
pas vouloir repartir d'entre eux
souhaitent 50 et 70% en attendant à peu
près ces chiffres et par contre on peut
être rassuré parce que je pense qu'il y
aura beaucoup de monde ici qui voudra
point de la place ce qui m'interroge un
peu après ces voix là est ce que après
c'est une chose mais ça ne doit pas être
une chose comme je dis ça doit pas être
une carrière ou un aboutissement de vie
juste un dernier mot sur ces campagnes
électorales en tout cas vous êtes élue à
la région vous l'avez dit là aussi c'est
un mandat que vous laisserez ah non non
non parce qu'enfin pas forcément je vais
je vais déjà attendre que l'on me pose
des questions si je peux repartir au
pralin région je l'étudierai pourquoi
pourquoi pas parce que bon il ya
beaucoup de belles justement en plus
c'est un monde à nouveau pour moi donc
c'est puis on n'a pas les mêmes j'allais
dire difficulté de gérer des équipes
municipales parce qu'on s'aperçoit que
gérer dumas c'est compliqué et gérer des
habitants en direct qui sont pas
satisfaits de choses dont on n'est plus
responsable
c'est effectivement compliqué j'irai la
raison d'une certaine façon
de ce côté là c'est plus confortable un
dernier mot sur l'actualité de votre
commune aujourd'hui quelle est votre
priorité
ma priorité c'est d'aller jusqu'au bout
des projets qu'on a engagés on a des
constructions en cours on a des preuves
de quelques petits projets me billet
parce qu'on en a quasiment pas sorti du
tout surtout de mandat pour différentes
raisons de foncier les procédures
l'interco les lois et cetera les
règlements et donc j'ai un certain
nombre de projets encore à terminer de
rénovation de bâtiments sportifs et des
vallées voir décliner à la population
très rapidement on a deux on a deux
réflexion très intéressante dans le
quartier nord pour la rénovation de la
gare qui va commencer mais qui va se
dérouler sur une période d'au moins 5
ans dans un contrat régional de dans
notre quartier ouest au niveau de la
place mandela on veut revoir aussi le
voilà et on a on a plein de encore 2
2 d'autre d'autres projets pour
justement que la ville soit le plus
attractive et aller jusqu'au bout de nos
engagements jusqu'à la dernière minute
avec la même passion voilà merci
beaucoup merci cdu en plateau pour ce
journal parlé de cette fin de mandat il
reste encore un peu de temps ce sera en
2020 les élections municipales merci à
vous merci le journal de ce 28 février
se poursuit à présent avec notre
portrait de la semaine vous l'avez sans
doute peut-être déjà rencontré c'est une
des figures de déclic théâtre nour el
yakine louis si les comédiens il anime
aussi des ateliers auprès des plus
jeunes pour partager sa passion
reportage mélanie poquet ce 24 janvier
l'heure est à l'installation comme
chaque année les équipes de déclic
théâtre investissent les collèges saint
quentinois
le match d'aujourd'hui c'est très
important de savoir c'est un match
amical on est bien d'accord
l'équipe qui gagne l'équipe qui perd on
s'en fiche il y a le collège gustave
courbet attrape celui des débuts de
noureev chine luis plus connu sous le
nom de no no 92 mon premier match
d'impro et puis courbet ça aussi le
collège ou ou aux baous djamel notamment
il ça on commence l improvisation et
puis plein d'autres qui ne sont pas
aujourd'hui des grandes stars du showbiz
mais en tout cas beaucoup de comédiens
ou de techniciens même je pense à hocine
à marion qui étaient là avec nous on a
tous eu notre beau coup on a fait nos
premiers pas ici à courber au sikkim
itno joue souvent larbitre celui qui
donne les thèmes et distribuer les
pénalités le méchant en apparence sympa
à l'ecoute joyeux toujours chamonix où
il est
les gentils quand on est quand on est
sur scène enfin il fait l arbitre qui
est méchant mais en vrai avec nous quand
la patinoire
il nous donne des conseils celui qui le
découvre c'est le fondateur de déclic
théâtre papy lors d'un atelier au
collège au lieu dit donc c'est pas mal
hein faut inscrire le mercredi est
inscrit sur les ateliers du midi donc
l'année commencé moi je m'inscris pas je
finis mon module je suis mon année comme
ça puis en cinquième j'ai retourné je
m'inscris le midi entre midi et deux
pour faire d'un pro mais très
sincèrement plus pour faire plaisir à
papa
une première année où ils s'estiment
insignifiant puis un déclic avec le
départ des plus grands un goût de faire
rire de la scène rejoint par une envie
de transmettre aux pm10 un atelier la
croix du bois pour les jeunes de voisins
machin et tout ac à venir ok donc moi je
suis à l'heure et il y a
vingtaine de jeunes qui sont là et
et pape sy ne vient pas un papy ou bien
par papy est pas là à l'heure prévue et
au bout de trois quarts d'heure papy qui
avait une galère sur la route papier
arrive et et moi en fait je le regarde
j'ai choisi ces bons et son show me dit
non non on continue donc je dis ah bon
diop a dit vas-y je te regarde nos mails
alors des ateliers s'occupe du secteur
improvisation il est aussi directeur
artistique des créations de la troupe
déclic et metteur en scène d'un seul en
scène le premier d'antoine rabot lui
aussi formé attrape un truc où tu vois
tu as un geste physique comme quand on
ferme les impros en quintet quoi tu vois
quelque chose qui vient pas perturber
par le déplacement le 2 mars prochain
antoine montera sur scène au guichet
montparnasse pour 1h d'improvisation
c'est un très grand pédagogue de ce que
je connais c'est ça doit être un des
meilleurs profs d'impro que j'ai pu
avoir jusqu'à la m6 arbitre responsable
de l'improvisation comédien metteur en
scène nono multiplie les casquettes avec
toujours un objectif transmettre son
amour de la scène et c'est la fin de ce
journal replay sur notre site internet
et notre application mobile lundi à 18h
vous retrouverez en direct grégory canal
et belle soirée
[Musique]